We've talked about how if you want to send a message and you want that message to have
integrity authenticity. We've talked about how if you want to send a message and you want that
message to have integrity authenticity and underpidiation that you should attach a digital signature
to the message and then you can send that message on to the receiver Nigel here and Nigel will if
you recall that digital signature is encrypted with my private key so Nigel needs to decrypt the
message with my public key but there's something we glossed over there and that is how does Nigel
have a copy of my public key and how do I have a copy of his public key so we need to talk about
a step that precedes sending our first message back and forth and that is that we need to exchange
our public keys so here's my public key Nigel needs to have a copy of my public key so I send him
a copy and he does the same he stores it and he does the same thing in reverse he sends me a copy
of his public key good okay excellent we now have a copy of each other's public keys and now I
create my message hash my message encrypt the hash value with my private key creating a
digital signature and I send that message over to Nigel and everything looks perfect here because
he decrypts my digital signature using the public key that he got for me and it proves authenticity
integrity and underpidiation everything looks perfect here right but there's a big flaw here
and the flaw is in the exchange of our public keys so let's replay the scenario again okay so here's
the fundamental problem when I send my public key to Nigel here my my main list just a little
munchkin is going to intercept that public key and instead of forwarding my public key onto Nigel
she's going to forward on her public key and so what Nigel in fact ends up with is not a copy of my
public key but our attackers our malicious munchkins public key so I roll my I send my key over to
Nigel what he receives is a copy of our malicious munchkins our attackers public key and the same
thing in reverse Nigel was sending me a copy of his public key but instead of sending receiving his
public key I get a copy of the malicious munchkins public key and so now both of us have our malicious
munchkins public key and we think I think I have Nigel's public key he thinks he has my public key
but what do we in fact have the malicious munchkins public key and here's the really good question
and I want you to think carefully about this do we know it is there any way that I can tell that
this is the malicious munchkins public key and not Nigel's public key and is there any way that he
can tell that he has the malicious munchkins public key and not my public key and the answer is there's
no way to tell and the reason being is that fundamentally what is a public key it's a number it's
a string of ones and zeros that's it that's all that a public key is and so if I have a string of
numbers I have no idea if that string of numbers belongs to the malicious munchkin or if it belongs
to Nigel and same thing for him and this is the really big problem that we have and that is how do
we verify the owner of a public key how do we know who a public key actually belongs to and the
solution to this problem is digital certificates so how do we go about getting a digital certificate
let's go back to Alice here let's say it's Alice that wants to create her own digital certificate
here's what Alice will do Alice will provide a little bit of information on herself
and a pot a copy of her public key and she will send this information to a certificate authority
you've probably heard of C.A.'s before what are some of the big well-known C.A.'s things like
Commodo, GoDaddy and Trust that's the best one in the world they're Canadian there's all these
different public C.A.'s and so what Alice is going to do is she's going to go to one of these big
public C.A.'s and she's going to provide that C.A. with a copy of her public key and a little bit
of information on herself including her name now the first thing that's going to happen is when
she sends this information to the certificate authority the C.A. is first going to identity
proofer his C.A.'s going to make sure if she says her name is Alice that she is in fact actually
Alice and not say our malicious munchkin so the first step our C.A. does is identity proofing
and then assuming that it's actually Alice that's providing her public key the certificate
authority will encrypt the information that Alice provided and that was a little bit of information
on herself and a copy of her public key and the certificate authority will encrypt this information
with the C.A.'s private key and that's it that's all that's required to create a digital certificate
it's simply the name of the owner and a little bit of information about them and a copy of the
owners public key all of that encrypted with the C.A.'s private key and that creates a digital
certificate and so a digital certificate is just a bit of a cipher text encrypted with the C.A.'s
private key so who can decrypt a digital certificate anyone that has the C.A.'s
public key and who has the big C.A.'s public key like who has come out or go daddy or
and trusts public key the answer is everyone has them how does everyone have them well these
big C.A.'s public keys their digital certificates come pre-installed in things like our browsers
and our operating systems and so you can assume that everyone has the big C.A.'s public keys
and therefore anyone can decrypt a digital certificate that comes from one of the big C.A.'s
so let's replay the scenario one final time
we start the scenario with sending each other our public keys but you never listen very carefully
here you never ever send someone a copy of your public key because anyone could intercept and
replace that public key and transit instead what you send someone is a copy of your digital certificate
so here's my digital certificate I am going to send my digital certificate over to Nigel
now our malicious munchkin is going to continue to be the malicious little munchkin that she is
she is going to intercept that digital certificate in transit can she decrypt the digital certificate
yes anyone can decrypt it so she can decrypt my digital certificate but can she replace my
public key inside the digital certificate with her own public key and the answer is most definitely
no there is no way that she can modify my digital certificate there's no way that she can remove
my public key and replace it with her public key because in order to modify or create a new digital
certificate she would need a copy of the C.A.'s private key and you can bet the C.A. does a very very
good job of protecting their private key and the same thing when Nigel sends his digital certificate
over to me our malicious munchkin here is going to intercept his digital certificate but she can't
modify it what if she were to send because what she did in the last scenario is she forwarded us
not our own public keys but her own and so instead of forwarding on my digital certificate to
Nigel what if she forwarded on her digital certificate and the same thing in the other direction
what if she forwarded on instead of Nigel's digital certificate to me she forwards on her own
digital certificate would Nigel and I know because when we just exchanged public keys
there was no way for us to know this but remember what does the digital certificate contain
it contains the owner it contains the public key and the name of the owner of the public key
and so the first thing that's going to happen is that when Nigel and I decrypt the digital
certificates that came from our malicious munchkin here what we're going to find is that instead of
saying you know instead of Nigel's digital certificate saying this belongs to Nigel it's going to
say it belongs to the malicious munchkin and when Nigel there decrypts my digital certificate he's
going to find that instead of it's saying it belongs to Robert belongs to the malicious munchkin
so digital certificates are the way that we solve this problem of mad in the middle attacks and
forging or replacing public keys digital certificates are how we bind an owner to their
public key so you know who a public key actually belongs to now one final piece that we need to cover
here and that is that there are lots of different certificate authorities around the world
and we want this whole system to be interoperable so that all of our different browsers all of our
different systems we can all use digital certificates from different sources and the way that we make
this whole system interoperable is we use standards and the standard by which we create digital
certificates is x 509 so just remember that the standard that we use to create digital certificates
so they're all created they all fall the same format is x 509